hello let's see how far I go now that
I've lost control I'm stuck here
grieving all alone I'm out of
Hope guess that's the way it goes when
you are dark and slow I'm can bring me
home no I'll S a f real quick
so when I don't come back I want you to
celebrate stay alive b
m
my when you s
me to Away St in my soul for your gra to
away I leave this wonderful place
I'm out of
pain Can You Feel My Rage of falling Far
From Grace can take me far away they see
with hate all I know is love and pain
drains the light from my face shine down
let me escape so I'm you black so when I
don't come back I want you to celebrate
say you
B
me
my you s me
fre to Away St in my stor great
to I leave this wonderful place
[Music]
I'll think a feel real Qui so when I
don't come back I want you to celebrate
see you laugh
very love it's my for
me let you s me for
me show
man and a light like
way love this wonderful place
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that flow
session uh real quickly I just want to
put out a huge thank you to ultra poy
for supporting my channel and my flow
sessions just like this one if you'd
like to get your own set of those uh or
poy Pro LED contact poy that I was using
in this video you can do so by using the
promo code drexfactor with a zero
instead of an o a checkout over at
ultra.com once again that is Drex factor
with a zero instead of an o thank you
once again to ultra poy for sponsoring
this video and speaking of thank yous uh
I have thanks to offer to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroar light toys spinballs and
Ultra poy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these amazing
companies by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to non-
business friend of the channel peka
ponin thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission finally this video would not be
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon in particular I'd love to
give a shout out to my flow patrons who
are listed on screen right now if you
like the work that I produce and you'd
like to see more of it easy way to make
that happen head on over to patreon at
patreon.com direct Factor Po and sign up
not only do you get access to some
pretty awesome rewards if I do say so
myself but also you'll be helping me out
of my mission to bring pois spinning and
flow Arts to the whole wide world so go
check that out please and thank you
finally if you want to check out more of
my flow sessions like this one I will go
ahead and include a link to a playlist
of those videos down in the description
as well as up on screen thank you so
much for watching make sure to get out
in flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now peace